[Music]
the White House says a new tariff on
solar products will create more jobs in
the United States but some industry
leaders disagree the new law places a 30
percent tariff on imported solar
products it will decrease by five
percent each year over a four year
period the u.s. solar industry is the
second largest in the world fine
China's in 2016 Americans spent twenty
three billion dollars on solar projects
Don Dahler is at a solar farm in
Branzburg New Jersey Don good morning
good morning kec solar is a state of the
art solar facility here in Branzburg New
Jersey on about 50 acres the u.s.
installed 12 billion watts that's how
they measure these things twelve billion
watts of solar last year compared that
with China which installed 50 billion in
fact all of these solar panels you see
here were made in China but the
president is hoping that his tariffs
will bring more manufacturing and jobs
to the American solar industry not
everyone agrees with that plan drone
footage showcases the seemingly endless
rows of solar panels at this 100 Acre
solar farm near Columbia South Carolina
what you see here is gonna power about a
thousand homes
Jamie Carlson showed us around the
property she's the executive vice
president of operations at Cypress Creek
renewables the company backing the solar
farm do you understand the concerns that
the the governments that subsidize these
solar panels to send them to the US that
it's it's unfair competition and they're
trying to level the playing field but I
think that's exactly what we need to be
considering how do we incentivize
manufacturing here in the US not just
focus on penalizing others my
administration is committed to defending
American companies and a president Trump
signed a tariff into law placing a 30%
tariff on imported solar products and
making this promise we're going to
benefit our consumers and we're going to
create a lot of jobs SolarWorld an
Oregon based solar panel manufacturer
helped petition the White House to
implement the tariff we have to level
the playing field the company told us it
laid off more than 300 of their 800
last year solarworld CEO Jurgen Stein
believes that tariffs will bring jobs
back to their factory that's about how
do we react to China with trying to
create a monopoly but Solar Energy
Industries Association CEO and president
abigail Ross hopper disagrees with the
administration's approach to creating
solar jobs you add a tax if you add cost
to something they're going to be fewer
people they're going to be able to buy
it if importers pass on the price
increase to consumers hopper worries
demand will drop negatively impacting
industry jobs according to the
Association there were about 260,000
Americans working in the solar industry
at the end of 2016 they estimate the
tariffs will cause a 23 thousand job
loss this year it's gonna be all
different kinds of people electricians
construction workers engineers
developers these racks are steel yes sir
made in America
Tom costos construction company is
installing the panels on the South
Carolina form do you think that there's
a chance that the terrorists might stop
you from getting some new projects
according to one energy research firm
the tariffs are expected to decrease
solar installations by 11 percent over a
five year period
hopper believes the industry will
continue to grow but at a slower pace
and do you not think this levels the
playing field I think just puts an
unnecessary barrier in Soler's way the
Solar Energy Industries Association
there's a mouthful for you tell us CBS
News that 90% of the solar panels used
in this country are imported but only
10% of those actually came from China
Gail alright got it done thank you very
much